Tương trình được chuyển khai trong 5 năm tưởng năm 2020,
hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành xấu thành phố chiming đặc mục tiêu
dây hành hành hành hành mục cành nhà, kở công dự án dạc văn thẳng
và hành hành mươi dự án chuyện tiếp.
Hành phố đã chuẩn bị 1 2 3 2 3 2 3,
khai căn hộ và nên đất tại đi cơ.
Đến 5 hành hành hành hành hành hành mươi sống nhà được dây dây lý kế giữ kến đặt
5 y một trong 3 chiến cân và phần đầu hành thẳng đưa vào sự dục,
mang in năm 2020, tương 1 bồn ngoài ngân xách và khở công 1 dự án dầu từ công
5 hành hành hành phố sẽ tăng tốt,
với việc dây dự lý kế 2 3 3 3,
tương đường xấu mới bá phẩy tả phần trong kế hoạt,
các dự án thức hiện theo phương thức, lối tắc, công tư,
phép phép phê, dự kiến đất khở công trong dạy này.
Đến 5 hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành phố sẽ hoàn thành dây dự dồi toàn bố
1 mốt nhiên, năm 2020, tương 1 bồn ngoài ngà bên cân dạch sau đó
các dự án sẽ tiếp tục hành thiệt hạt tăng công viên kế xanh,
nghiêm thu và bản dọ đưa vào sự dục.
Hảo sát của sử dụng cho thấy khoảng 6h tình trong hồ dân
lựa cho những tiền bồn thường theo giá thị trường và thức lòng nữa ờ.
Quang 4 mốt nhất, tương đường, mấy lâm dình hai chăm tảm,
mấy lâm cân và niên có như cầu được bồn trị tảy đến cơ.
Gió phần lớn nhà bên cân dạch không đủ được kiện bồn thường về đất,
gió lần chí hắn.
Thành phố dựa kiến án dụng cơ, chỉ đặt thù sử dụng nhở xa hội để mũ chỉ đến cơ.